翻訳: Eri Katayama
校正: Maki Sugimoto
みなさん こんにちは
教育界の松岡修造こと
松田悠介です
教育の話になってしまうと
どうしても熱くなってしまうせいか
最近は松岡さんに似ていますねと
言われるんですが
情熱こそが人生を切り拓く
源だと思っている 私にとっては
大変光栄なことです
松岡さんといえば錦織 圭選手
昨年の全米オープンで
日本人初の準優勝を成し遂げました
錦織選手は 翌日のインタビューの中で
インタビュアーである松岡さんに
こう答えています
"修造チャレンジ があったから
世界を見据えるようになりました
今の自分があるのは
修造さんのおかげです"
本当に素敵な関係で
私は感動しました
きっと誰の人生にも
人生を変える出会いがあるんだと思います
まず最初に一人の教師との
出会いによって
人生が変わったある少年の話を
したいと思います
1997年 ある少年は
当時中学校２年生でした
勉強が全然できず
常に400人の中で学年最下位
運動も全然ダメで 体も小さく
体は貧弱で
中学校２年生の頃から
ひどいいじめに あい始めます
柔道部の同級生がやってきては
柔道技をかけていく毎日
時には 後遺症が残るような
暴力も受けました
自殺を考えたこともあります
その少年の人生が変わるきっかけ
となったのが
体育の松野先生のある一言でした
"なあ いじめる側が
99%悪いかもしれない
でも おまえにも１% 何かしら
今の状況を変えられるかもしれない
それを一緒に考えて
行動に移していこう"
その日から 少年の人生は
少しずつ変わることになります
先生は少年と一緒に
いじめを抜け出す戦略を考え
体を強くしようという作戦が決まれば
全力で実行をサポートしていきました
少年は１日２リットルずつ
牛乳を飲み
早寝早起きを徹底して
そうすると みるみる
身長は伸びました
体を鍛えるために
毎朝６時半に学校に登校しては
トレーニングをしていくと
体は強くなっていき
いつの日か いじめは
なくなりました
大嫌いだった体育も いつのまにか
活躍できるようになっていき 大好きになり
体育係 体育祭実行委員長 陸上部の部長
も務めるようになりました
いつの日か少年は
自分がそうであったように
厳しい状況にある子供達と向き合い
人生を変えられるような
"教師"という職業に憧れ
志すようになっていきます
大学に進学し 教員免許を取得して
卒業後 都内の中学校で
体育教師として勤務をします
夢が叶ったんです
でも 夢はそこにとどまることなく
教育現場で垣間見えた
日本全体の教育課題を
解決してゆくべく
死に物狂いで勉強をして
ハーバードに留学して
帰国後 教育系のNPOを
立ち上げることになります
そして今日 ここに立つことが
できています
そう その少年は私です
松野先生がいなかったら
私の人生はどうなっていたでしょうか？
おそらく今日 みなさんの前で ここで
話をすることはなかったと思います
私は 教育というのは
子供の前に立つ教師の質で
決まるという風に思っています
言い方を変えれば
教育というプロセスにおいて
子供が悪いということは
何一つないんです
何一つです
私は中学校の教員時代
いわゆる学級崩壊を引き起こして
しまうような先生の
職員室のある会話を
耳にしました
"今日も授業になんなかったよ
あいつら ほんとうるせえな"
"そうですか 参りますね"
それを聞いて私は
強い違和感を感じました
学級崩壊を引き起こすのは
子供のせいじゃない
教師がどういう想いで
どう授業を設計して
何を伝えるのか
そこに問題があるんだと
生徒は教師を映す鏡です
子供達は大人を映す鏡です
私は子供が悪いということは
何一つ無いと思っているので
どうすれば厳しい状況にある子供達の
教育環境を改善していけるのかというのを
必死に考えるようになります
今のTeach For Japanの活動は
教員の採用の質にフォーカスして
徹底してそこを考えています
少しだけTeach For Japanの紹介を
させてください
25年前 一人の女子大生が
アメリカの教育格差の問題を是正すべく
あるプログラムを立ち上げます
Teach For Japanの前例となっている
Teach For Americaというモデルです
彼女はこの 厳しい状況にいる子供達の
状況 環境を改善していくためには
優秀な人材を投入していかなければいけない
ということを確信し
全米で 優秀で情熱のある人材を
教員として２年間
困難な状況を抱えている子達が多い学校に
派遣するプログラムをスタートしています
今では 年間6000名
現場に派遣されているような
プログラムに成長しています
厳しい状況と向き合う
子供達 教師達は
日々 子供達と向き合う中で
成長を促していき
さらに リーダーシップを
徹底して磨くことになります
このリーダーシップこそが
のちのこの人達の
人生の大きな 大きな
財産になっていきます
Teach For Americaの卒業生達は
卒業後 教育現場のみならず
政治 NPO 行政 ビジネス
いろんなセクターで
リーダーとして活躍していく
ようになります
教えることを通して 学ぶ 成長する
このプログラムは広く認知され
Teach For America 2010年の
文系の就職ランキングにおいては
一位になり
GoogleやAppleを抜くような
人気就職先ランキング 人気組織に
なっていきました
私は留学中に このモデルと出会い
このモデルを日本で実現していかなければ
いけないと 強い想いを持ち
2012年にTeach For Japanを
立ち上げております
日本にも深刻な
教育格差の問題があります
6人に1人の子供が貧困状態に苦しんでいる
というふうにも言われています
貧困がもたらすのは
格差の問題です
学力格差の問題どういった高校に
進学できるのかも決まってしまい
大学の進学率にも
影響を与えていきます
そういった子供達が大人になったときに
就ける仕事も限定的になってしまい
得られる賃金にも影響を与え
自分の子供に与えられる教育も
限定的になってしまいます
貧困の連鎖の問題です
昨年の1月 大阪で
母子 母と子の餓死の事件がありました
母親の隣に
３歳のルイ君が横たわっていて
毛布がかけてあって
その隣に置手紙が置いてありました
"最期にお腹いっぱい食べさせて
あげなくてごめんね"
私はラッキーだから
ここに立っているだけであって
もしかしたら 死んでいったルイ君だったかも
しれないということを考えると
子供の教育問題には
強い当事者意識を持って
取り組むことができます
子供達は 生まれる環境を
選ぶことができません
生まれた地域環境や家庭環境によって
子供の人生が左右されている中
我々は何をしていくべきなのかというのを
日々考えていくべきだ
というふうに思っています
Teach For Japanは
毎年 今のところ24名のですね
人材を採用し 厳しい状況にいる
子供達が多い学校に
教員として 派遣をしております
中には商社やメーカーで
輝かしい実績を残した人材もいれば
青年海外協力隊や国境なき医師団で
多様なグローバル経験を積んだ
人材もいます
こういった人材が 子供と向き合い
寄り添うことで
日々 子供達のみならず
親御さんとも信頼関係を
築いていくことになります
さらにTeach For Japanはこういった
秀でた成果をあげている先生のことを
徹底的に分析をしていき
これからの教員採用のあり方
これからの教育行政のあり方
というのを体系化していく
のみならず
連携する教育委員会と
我々の情報を提供していく中で
政策提議も進めていこう
と思っています
一人でも多く松野先生を
増やしていけるように
ここにいらっしゃる多くの方々は
ご存知かもしれませんが
ICUの初代学長である湯浅先生は
こんな言葉を残されています
"生きることは 愛すること
愛することは 理解すること
理解することは 許すこと
許すことは 許されること
許されることは
救われること"
許すというのは 受け入れる
ということだと思います
子供達の千差万別の個性
家庭環境 夢を
全て受け入れることが
子供達と接する
第一歩目だと思います
私は中学校2年生のときに
松野先生の一言で許され
人生が大きく変わりました
私は日々 自問自答しています
"当時の自分に出会ったならば
どんな言葉をかけることができ
どんな指針を与えることができるのだろうか"
昨今 悲しいことに
子供の貧困の問題なり いじめの問題を
よくニュースで耳に
することがあります
こういった状況にいる子供達に
我々が何ができるんだろうか
日々 考えていくべきだと思うのです
教育改革というのは
教師だけの仕事ではなく
我々大人 全員の使命であり
社会全体の責任だと思います
今日 この場にいらっしゃる
皆様がたが
熱い教育改革をご一緒いただける
仲間になることを信じて
最後に この言葉を贈りたいと思います
"暑くなければ 夏じゃない
熱くなければ 人生じゃない"
ご静聴ありがとうございました
(拍手)